welcome back to pj chain design this is
pj today i would like to show you
this process ring with the rhino7
and how to make them connection is
really smooth are you ready let's get
started
[Music]
before we're starting this demonstration
i want to talk about the structure as
you can see one side is darker than the
other side which means it has reflect or
it's like a rhino uh mirror going to the
other side so you can see this two sides
right there so ideally as soon as we can
check one side done that would be fine
and the structure wise is we are going
to making this ring first right in the
middle and we are going to making this
prong right here and we just kind of
connect it in between all right so we'll
get this nice split prong there so
that's starting from the scratch so
we're gonna come into the front view use
the circle command to creating the ring
size in this case i wanted to make sure
it is
about 16 millimeter and you can make any
size that you wanted for your ring to
start with and i'm going to come into
the side to create a profile for my ring
in this case i want to make sure that
it's the right thickness and everything
that i wanted so i'm going to click ok
and moving this back to the center right
here so now we have those two curves we
are going to using the sub d tool under
the tab right here you are on the
standard and now you want to pick up the
subby so those are the subtly tools that
you can use or you can come into the
drop down menu and you have the sub d
sub menu and those are all the sub d
tool okay to creating a ring in the sub
d we are going to use this sub the sweep
one rail and we're gonna pick up the
rail pick up the cross section and hit
enter then you will get the window like
this
now how many section do you want to have
is up to you in this case i might need
to have a mall section so i'm going to
increasing this into the 12 and see
where is the prong that i'm going to
have right there
and see if that is enough you can
increasing those number if you want to
and but i would like to stay with the 8
and the 12. okay let's click ok now we
have this surface right here you can see
it's a closed
softie surface okay and the second thing
is we are going to call in our stone you
can sign up my newsletter at the
description below and then you will get
the brownstone to download and i just
call the song in by copy and paste from
the stone file that you download okay so
now we have this stone right here it's
up to you want to make them bigger or
smaller the stone that i have there is
for five millimeter i do want to make a
really blink diamond ring so i might
wanted to have it bigger like this okay
so now i have is my stone ready i need
to creating my prong coming into the
circle command or you can use a square
if that worked for you i'm going to
creating a circle snipping where it's
almost like 45 degree there and to
decide how big of the circle that i
wanted for my prong and of course you
don't want to the prong is cutting way
too much all right once we are turning
into a circle we need to make sure it is
a supple friendly curve if you click on
here it's just a it's a closed curve
right so ideally is we aren't creating a
surface and if we are having this
surface and then we can blend it into
one of the surface here but to blend it
not blend it
to
bridges in the subtlety instead of blend
that you will need to have a bullseye
it's the same type of a model in order
to breach so if this is a poly surface
it's not going to work right so let's go
ahead to rebuild this guy and we want to
rebuild into a point count into four and
make sure it's a subtly friendly curve
the reason we wanted to have s4 is
because this surface that we are going
to blend uh bridge into is a full size
of the surface as well okay so let me
simply just extrude it a little bit so
you can kind of see what kind of this
surface the area that we are going to
cut into it right now i'm going to come
into the selection and pick up this
surface and we want to delete it so
ideally two sides the same they have
four edges here for the supply surface
and we have four edges here for the
subway surface let's go ahead and give
it a try we are going to use the bridge
command in the sub d and then we are
going to pick up uh the h for the first
set as one two three and four and you
hit enter and pick up the second set one
two three and four make sure both side
the number has to be the same right then
you will get something like this and
notice that it's like really pointed
right there but that's okay we can
always edit uh you can increase in the
section in the middle so you can have
more things to tweak if you want to and
you can join them if you want to okay so
that's click ok then i will have
something like this okay now let's take
a look this might be like a two
caving too much and maybe i want to make
it more smoother so i'm going to pick up
all this curve uh on my subject curve
and i just want to delete this right and
then now i can pick up the surface um
this all in the loop and i want to bring
out a little bit if i do not want to
have the bottom that's so thick i can
kind of taper it and bring in and then
you can kind of tweak it into the way
that you like right maybe right in the
middle here it's way too much i'm kind
of tapering too much and then you can do
1d scale it's up to you how you like to
uh i like to do it now you can also
bring up specific only on this curve
instead of like caving a lot you might
want to have the button is a little bit
stronger so it's up to you how you like
to address it now i kind of feel like
this curve right here it might be too
much in so maybe you wanted to make them
smoother by bringing them out so i have
a better transition in this area right
so those are really basic something that
we can play with now we have this and we
can simply just cap it
uh in the subthe instead of using the
cap you have to something is called fill
sub d hole and then you're gonna pick up
all these uh edges here and hit enter
then you will get something like this
now after we got this of course it is
for the setting this is like way too
thin so i'm going to pick up all this
and in case i'm picking up the stone i'm
going to
lock the stone that right there just in
case i accidentally pick up the stone so
let's go ahead to lock the stone all
right so now let's go back with the
sub-d tool we want to pick up the faces
make them a little bit longer so we can
drag them right there i might want to
just pick up uh the curve
and have them to go
down a little bit right there
and then again go back to the top i may
want to pick up only these faces and
bring up a little bit and you can also
take a look on the top view how much you
want to cut into it right and again if
you feel like this curve is too tilted
you can also pick up this curve right
here on the surface and i kind of want
to bring it back a little bit so it's a
bit puffier on this side so go ahead to
tweak into the way that you think the
prong should be once we've done the
prong and we all want to do is a
symmetrical on all of them so simply
what we wanted to do is using the
reflect command in the sub d then you
want to pick up the sub that you want to
reflect it will ask you you want to
reflect x-axis or y-axis so in this case
we want to pick up the x-axis it will
pick up like which side you wanted to
keep so we want to click on the side
that we want and just hit enter so that
will go to the other side exactly the
same the good thing about this is if
you're in the sub d and you feel like i
need to tweak a little bit more i want
to move this the other side will move it
together it's because it's it's reflect
okay so once you like whatever that you
have there you can do the reflect one
more time so we want to reflect here and
we wanted to click on the subtitle we
want to apply and this time we want to
pick up the y-axis and let's go ahead to
pick it up on the right side and hit
enter and that will reflect over there
so now right and the left is reflect as
well the wipe
is the spot that you can changing uh you
can keep tweaking for example i still
feel like the middle part might be too
thick so i'm going to pick up those
curve and just do the 1d scale to scale
it down and you can keep tweaking until
you find the shape that you like like
what i have right here on this curve i
may bring in too much and to make it
this one too strong for example so i can
kind of want this scale it down to make
it more elegant and to took it into the
way i like once you like everything you
just turn them into
the poly surface and they will be ready
for casting i hope you enjoyed the video
i do have a course for specific on the
subd and that is this on my website that
teach you every detail about the subdi
and organize and 3d model the organic
form thank you for watching and i will
see you next
[Music]
foreign